we're back we're back with resident evil
episode 5 so I didn't save why mean I
saved but I lost like maybe five minutes
yeah we did that spoiler esting at the
end of last episode so I'm gonna redo
the part where I know I need a lantern
and the last time I saw the lantern was
Marguerite's lantern or like in the pool
of sludge Lord so I never saw this
really good at that like causing like
dread like when you know you have to go
to the basement or something should I
say yeah I would also like stock up man
yes is there anything in here that would
help me or no I don't think so
I almost went now a fair amount of uh in
your old handgun I don't know if you
haven't if you could swap in the new
hangar but you have the go oh yeah no
you're right you have to go to the thing
anyway yeah ten special rounds let me
just go [ __ ] I think I went the wrong
way
go this way
everything's so gross I hate bugs
okay I think I'm good sorry
I like stress myself out thinking about
bugs okay so let's get stuff decide what
we need and then ooh and then save and
then we'll go holy [ __ ]
actually you know what I just realized
as well what there's something else we
should do
yeah remember you got the crow key that
allowed you upstairs yeah you remember
where else you can use the croaky um
back at the other house yeah in that
fireplace room I highly encourage you to
do that now yes okay so do I need this
crank no I think you tell me that okay I
I have handgun ammo and I have a shotgun
with one bullet
should I just get rid of that so that I
have more squares left I'll get a
shotgun came across shells okay and then
so I have three of these and I have some
chem fluid and I think that's all I need
but no we have four slots I would keep
the psychostimulants in case but now I
only have four slots and like would I go
to the house and then come back and save
again like what are the odds there's
gonna be something in the house how'd
you like what I'm saying is I can get
rid of this and now I have two more so
do you remember what was behind the
crowd or we I said like told you to peek
through the side you probably remember
this if we don't if we didn't play one
Episode a week here it was that you saw
like a weapon yeah so just keep that in
mind
so okay be a one-handed weapon and take
up one square or could be two-handed
take up two of those so I'm just saying
I have 27 bullets so I feel like I'm
okay for your handgun for now yeah yeah
anyone that like when I go after Spidey
laids
yeah yeah sure but I'm just going back
to the house are we doing that or are we
doing - Spidey laid no which one should
i do first back to the house okay so get
a weapon - all right so I'm going to I'm
going back to the house I'm gonna get
weapon and this episode we're gonna kill
spidey lids here we go god I've got a
knife you're probably better off okay
everybody
saving back to the mansion instead of
coming all the way over here and then I
don't know
we'll cross that bridge win god I hate
bugs and I'm only comfort and it is on
fire up goo on it so gross I it's a
testament to how good this games world
design is that despite how gross it is I
still love it
like that's such a weird way to frame
maybe you're just like really into weird
stuff cuz you're a weirdo I have
fetishes that involve goo and spider
women no probably never it's just never
satisfied just these women are not
spider you know that fan gets you all
the time
it's the left right yeah the shotgun
statue so it's to the left or is it in
is it in my hole yeah go through the
safety hole sweet sweet home still
scares me
like I'll never feel comfortable unless
I'm in one of these little hidey holes
yeah all right so there's the door okay
another crow door downstairs I can't
remember there was that a snake okay
there's a lot of stuff in here I'm gonna
shut that should I pop some stimulants
no it's a small enough for me you can
just comb it okay nice oh my god we're
gonna have a ramshackle that [ __ ]
thing is classic resin evil weapon
Revelations 1 & 2 came out on switch
last weekend I actually got them playing
through powder that's great yeah check
on her stuff they've often hid stuff
under there pardon me I'm gonna be in my
funk like 10 seconds what are you doing
I'm just double-checking something from
my memory I'm not gonna tell you though
okay it's about the game I played this
in VR over the weekend it is one of them
you [ __ ] do you saying that - you were
the producers yeah the directors could
be me who knows well was it some chem
fluid but I think was the good stuff oh
yeah strong complete it was like really
old enough all right so go back I don't
think there's another cars go back yeah
well okay so say it like they do in home
alone go back go back
no um I just watched that the other
night - man we are Slumdog Millionaire
in this conversation let's what do you
want go to this save room rather than go
no no no that's one so go it's gonna be
quicker to go from here to where just go
to this save room
yeah cuz this you can stock up here and
then your fight Marguerite rather than
go all the way the other side of the old
house I have anxiety yeah Oh God
remember when the grandma was here yeah
you haven't seen her while she's
upstairs at one point - I hope you never
have to fight her okay
so strong chem fluid no yeah keep that
really you want to keep it you always
tell me not to keep this well you're not
always confronting I'm one of the main
NPCs okay so I'll keep this what about
do I need the rocket launcher the
grenade launcher I'd take it yeah you
know you don't need the croaky anymore
what about the solid fuel because then I
have to take this the fuel gun which I
don't have the flamethrower yeah I put
it in a bin oh yeah no I wouldn't bring
the flamethrower
you don't okay then I don't need these
hockey pucks wait can burn a fuel be
combined for grenade rounds - I don't
think so I definitely take the handgun
rounds
okay so handgun rounds grenade launcher
grenade shotgun shells but I don't have
a shotgun take that other regular chem
fluid I would just save a strong one no
bring those those are been eight rounds
you'll want those I think what you just
got rid of your uh flame sorry I
recommend bringing them as backup
so flame rounds yes wrong ten fluid no
no yeah take that
oh I'm confused take that take the
regular scan fluid up here I have a
regular chem fluid just take another one
because you have multiple herbs
well they don't stack okay you should be
good get to put get your shotgun and put
those shells down
take the shotgun and take the shells
it's all you're saying yeah I I have two
slots I know but you're not like like I
said I wouldn't guide you as much if I
didn't think you have to just double
back and be a boring episode since a box
so I'm trying to make sure you don't
double back I mean ever I'm gonna die
well you're hanging out with my save
okay
cold l damn those a strong handgun
rounds are tied to your other handgun I
think what do you mean
remember you made those advance or did
you I don't remember
I checked check your other handgun quick
oh sorry
cuz you might be with not might be
wasting ten the g17 yeah I just put in
your inventory so I could see that quick
and uh I don't know how go back just
move it up to your like knifes law and
take it out I don't think you should
have to do that whatever how do I do
that again
that's square press X on the knife
slaughter where
we square it did yeah yeah oh I see yeah
sorry sorry it's just paint
so now pull that one out yes your
powerful ones are tied to that how power
ones oh it's just one though no that's a
regular that's just one are you doing
what my dissent is are those increased
power rounds I don't remember yeah you
don't need this figure it out later
you're fine okay and just okay I'm going
no I got a save and then I'm gonna go
sweet I hate spiders and bugs and women
so this is like the ultimate this is
like it yes yeah that's right sorry
this actually does remind me of the
first game cuz I kept I would like do
left and you'd be like no go right and
be like right of course and then I think
you'd be like no turn around be like
yeah okay got it
never knew it is going that was so long
ago a year it's about a year over a year
cuz we started over a year ago with the
intention of ending in February it was
either January or February game on I do
not want to go down there oh god lord
oh god I'm also an idiot you could have
just gone to the trailer save great
whatever should I shut it no [ __ ] that's
special that's such a dumb line I would
never have said that in real life
yeah like he's so [ __ ] calm and cool
you've never seen this [ __ ] in your life
that's why it's special doesn't make any
sense
do you need to be crouched right now yes
no no it's like I need to like I feel
better
Oh God
[ __ ] this is gross remember that movie
we watch for dead air borderlands that
one of the first two recommended movies
watch where they die like in that
stomach tube at the end this reminds me
we I don't know where I am
oh god I have so much anxiety let's
start going up here I guess oh no it's
got to be me we say get your earrings
before you you're following MIT to
anything yeah you're following the
maggots so I don't have to go up there I
just know that that's where she is
oh it's a toilet ashtray full of
cigarettes that's where I came from
yeah I don't know what that is the
trailer yeah you got a shortcut back oh
that's nice so now I can get saved now
if you want should I probably easier
autosave would have taken care of it but
yeah you could it did like I said I'm
kind of dumb for not just having you I
altered it in my memory I could remember
a few right away yeah turn the gameplay
volume down a tiny bit you should turn
me down because I am gonna [ __ ]
scream when I see her cuz she's gonna be
gross and I know it I know she's gonna
upset me see like people that know this
game well I can like see them skipping
likes like kind of she's in there which
means there's also over here I can see
people scrubbing through the video to
find like certain points that they know
something happens okay so that's how I
come out all right you ready
hmm I know I'm not
do you read any comments on last week's
episode no people are pumped for this
episode which usually bodes ill for you
[ __ ] no no she's yelling she made a
noise I'm actually like a little too
scared she in that hole cuz it was it
Abby from Giant Bomb that couldn't
finish this game cuz it was it's gonna
be me do it for the fans no I owe you
nothing what what I turn around okay
check that no she's not in there she's
not be funny though like it crawling out
of the fridge I bet you she's on the
ceiling or some [ __ ] she's gonna [ __ ]
come at it I really don't want to look
up to you know Jesus Mary okay yeah I
think I can't take any more items sorter
don't let me forget about this separate
I won't keep mind it's game you'll
you'll do some backtracking most the
time oh I don't want to the only way
down go into her hole no oh my god
you're shotgun out if it makes you feel
safer it does and reload god damn it
Mary have I taught you nothing [ __ ]
one shell ready to go
Oh God you [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] they did this on purpose
it's so dark in here that noise smells
like smells sounds like sounds like mice
yeah
mice are bugs okay that's locked so I
have to go this way I'm on yellow so I
can only get hit once before I hit r1
got it runs on it depends on though I
feel fine oh god what was that
okay it's a ladder okay where are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god I can't do this I
can't
I actually I feel really unko god that's
a all right huh
I'm too scared I'm too scared
what is that you okay I have to hit this
okay cool
you're scaring me and I played this
twice before I I'm [ __ ] freaking out
I do not like spiders she's gonna come
out of the goddamn ceiling I just know
it there's not enough bullets in the
world for this fight I like don't know
I'll be drinking coffee during this game
oh you [ __ ] where is she watch stop
don't make any noises I'm so scared I'm
gonna have a heart attack where is it
spider spider I hid my [ __ ] mouth on
the mic
okay so I can't I don't I need to come
back here
well no no okay I'm probably bring the
fire oh yeah I don't so I think you
could swipe them off because the last
time you tried stabbing them I think you
could swipe them with your knife off I'm
just not gonna go over there cuz I don't
need to use these right or do I need to
use that door I would try swiping that
door with what your knife you tried
stabbing him just get the right distance
and then swipe like the regular attack
I'm killing your children oh I'm fine
with this I just wanna make sure heavy
funny she's back there oh god shut up
yeah that's good so that's a loop
assuming you do get attacked in here oh
you might as well do the other one do
that to the cabinet in case you need to
grab those you know in case all right
folks I know just Prime TV shotgun
shells and strong influence re okay
that's worth it to me
I also yeah oh [ __ ] okay I also mentally
feel better like killing some spiders
yeah okay alright so tell me how a
rocket launcher works it's a grenade
launcher tell me how one of those works
like are they gonna explode on impact or
balance I think the balance where I
started exploring them I go upstairs
right oh gosh there's a door
yeah I think the grenades explode on
impact if they're incendiary I'm pretty
sure I do okay please don't be on the
ceiling please don't be on the ceiling
I wasn't looking the right way yeah you
were looking in the perfect direction
for that to happen we're [ __ ] just
use your playground killer what just
green house fight where is she she's
[ __ ] gross shoot the yeast infection
oh [ __ ] oh my god she's gonna kill me me
who she's [ __ ] no you're fine got
shooter in that heal up or Ilana yeah
why am I not running again
nothing you can while you're feeling
where she where the [ __ ] are you oh god
she's so gross they got him oh he'll
weird China okay
oh my god she's so good
you see I'm trying I need to make it
I'll go r1 oh right yeah hey got nice so
wait every time she hurts me is it a
thing it just depends on the attack I
think she just smoked you bad thank God
I can't see her and I'm so slow dude I'm
so slow
where is she where is she
this is the worst this is a nightmare
I can hear her [ __ ] gross Fupa
getting closer to me what is that [ __ ]
what is that flies they're gonna rain
like yeah echoes not saying but don't
shoot I really don't have time for you
run oh my god this is the nightmare
scenario yeah just go [ __ ] right at
it when it stops
so yeah you like do damage sure
let me just let me just process what
happens me oh no [ __ ] the points are
wood
you didn't tell me about this I don't
have a way to protect myself
you shock on them I don't know if it's
pretty might not be worth that's better
than dying not ideal but this is a
mistake
oh I'm gonna die uh you have any help
nope
now you can eaten herb oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm gonna die - bugs
oh Jesus this is unfortunate Oh God
Wow whatever even grabbed the flame
throw this time shot right past I think
that's one of the more infamous scares
is the landing the window she busts
through I missed it
still pretty funny though cuz I don't
think I've ever seen anybody looking up
when that happens I was so sure she was
gonna be on the ceiling oh crap when you
leave then
yeah the trailer is right there oh my
god that she is disgusting like with her
little belly and stuff yeah
oh wait go go through the website okay
Oh gross
they made her real vile well alright so
I can't keep all these guns like I got
to get rid of some stuff here I think I
should premix things give her the
treasure photo a and the Gunpowder oh
yeah that's real dumb okay and then I
could pre make some stuff I'm obviously
gonna need more yeah all right so you're
telling me to keep this thing right is
that what you're saying
mmm no I'd take the regular chem fluid
and you'll also find the other strong
chemical odor in the greenhouse yeah and
then I need make maybe a flamethrower
okay yeah but can you equip the
flamethrower from the I'm gonna need a
hockey puck oh I have one yeah press X
on the flanker oh yeah
no no you need the hockey pucks you need
to make combined with something okay so
maybe like that
yeah but make sure you can equip the
grenade and make sure you know how to
create B equip the grenade launcher from
the menu I don't know how she's got
press X on it go down to flank yeah
co-op maybe you just didn't just need to
square to switch it during the fight if
you need it I would I'd honestly just
recommend that over your knife I don't
need a knife like when am I ever gonna
use a knife in this fight there are
boxes in there that you didn't see okay
take all this stuff I'm gonna come back
right what do you mean I can always come
back yeah but out but I would put your
grenade launcher over the knife and that
click select oh I don't think you can
you can't I understand
okay I'm ready real more likely I
switched today okay I'm ready oh you
[ __ ] dirty [ __ ]
she's so scary did you wait I'm sorry
what did you get did you have extra
burner fuel you have like nothing I have
you come on puck that's not a mold you
have to combine that with chem fluids
should I go back how many bullets do I
need I'm not gonna need to make bullets
you're gonna need to make yeah I guess
Emma or a life yeah make that with the
chem fluid okay so combined with this
yeah and then just reload your
flamethrower so you're right right now
yeah there you go now you've got more
space - should I go get a chem fluid no
I think you'll pick one up in the house
yeah
now I don't have a knife in my bar so I
can't get rid of those spiders don't
pick that up I'm not going to
oh my gosh my throat hurts from like
that screams oh man
yikes okay my heart still hurts from
this whole experience okay so I'm gonna
to kill those spiders again will 9 yeah
but I would use the burner fuel I'm
gonna need that for the fight you can
open that box right now - how do I use
it do I have to put it on my face so
that's inconvenient yeah oh good you
still need it but the chem fluid you'll
find other chemicals I feel like you and
I aren't on the same page it's a
marathon not a sprint you'll listen I
really don't want to do this yes you'll
defend yourself
most flies which were pretty much your
demise do I want those now I'm like
really out of I'll come back they're
helpful in that they're up there also
one thing that you might not think of
they're helpful in the middle of a fight
when you don't have time to I scour
every inch
they're done yeah okay there's one and
then here's the other there you go and
I'll take shotgun
both of these sure okay okay okay
and then I switched to my shotgun and
then she's got a lot of ammo you could
make a strong med kit thing right now if
you wanted want me to yeah
look you've got a bunch of shotgun
shells and handgun rounds and Brenna
feel yeah you'll clear up space for
anything else okay okay I'm ready
I thought it was in a second I thought
it was the next stair I thought it was
the next one yeah I thought it was up
here where she just keep moving in
general I know that sounds obvious but
where she and don't waste I got it
you are not a girl okay should I do
another one like right now every load
[ __ ] there spiders over there it takes
to say you didn't reload where is it you
she's so gross
why are you why are you Oh God
oh she's so gross
where's she I wasted it it's alright but
I can't live like this
can I put fire on her yeah
yeah all right stop stop something wait
she's in spider form yoo-hoo shotguns
you good right now
really yeah save the fuel for the
smaller dudes okay oh god she's [ __ ]
so gross
I'm like I can't believe I wasted that
thing I'm sorry it was honestly worth
the Compu laughs like oh my god I'm so I
would get so afraid because I thought
she was coming from above again oh I
hear her oh [ __ ] she doing [ __ ] wait
she's glitching out yeah she's still
there I don't know I'm humping before I
can't look she's still stuck
go get that yet I can't let you go check
I can't look oh there's a cabinet back
well hope she's not stuck cause any left
of Reese
where is she oh [ __ ] she's there knock
on it
yeah what do you want me to those things
are the fire help or you're denying yet
[ __ ] you
yeah new you shock on her I'm trying to
cooking you haven't even had to heal yet
you have more ammo than I can I uh well
where is she
you I hear her which is not there's an
herb in the ground wait I thought I'd
gotten more fuel you did you just have
to reload I did look a grenade launcher
all right should I use it on this thing
since you're out of grenades I would
just put the knife where your grenade
launcher is just keep moving in those
weren't hurt
there you go and then own oh all right
so chugun
yeah he's like yellow yeah hurry up
shotgun her syphilis photo she caught me
no duh
and try to keep looping whatever
possible just so you know where I am
you're upstairs you're downstairs let's
not walk there are nude stairs I don't
know how to get yeah yeah yeah one more
to her yeah yeah how do you know she's
taking damage it's not like res evil six
where you don't know if she's well
what's she doing sorry to sound like a
broken record but try to keep moving
because she can come at you from above
oh god [ __ ] alright I'm going up is that
okay yeah do whatever you want I'm just
like I would say to put one thing I
would say is don't stay still what was
that do you think I'm okay here for a
little bit remember when you're a fly
buzzing around
I hear it too but I don't get a knife
out brother there you go you [ __ ]
little there's three
he's got lunch at him hurry up I don't
have all day
ooop up I'm working on it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he she swiped my leg come
on that's so gross you have your
powerful once you can attack right now
yeah I'm only on I don't know [ __ ]
[Music]
bastards yeah they suck
I'm already on yellow makeup make
another when you kill these guys make
another help and conserve your fuel like
get your knife out unless they're just
this one guy heard that good handgun to
keep that in mind but your shotguns yeah
just run I can't live like this
don't flame well where is she
like if she's around I can't stab them I
don't have time if you keep moving
they'll follow you faster than she whoa
all right so wait shotgun or what what
do you think you got a reload first but
she killed me stupid she's coming out
you can still run away no need to make a
decision right now but yeah shotguns get
that that's it they only got two please
don't kill me he got it she got at me
I'm gutted so I gotta keep moving
I [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't feel like I did
she's so hard to kill I'm gonna die she
keeps cutting me keep moving
we're just keep running away and getting
so bad I thought I was doing good but
then these bullets are so tiny she's so
gross got some boxes you could open too
did she do the thing I'm so slow
I can't stand it boo bop boop up chants
[ __ ] god damn it I mama's
still items lying around I don't have
time I'm trying not to die here so go up
or what yeah
I'm really stressed out laters no I like
think I'm dying to herbs there's that I
can't fluid down hit that box shotgun
shells and I'm so [ __ ] slow like I'm
so slow I saw that did you see her yeah
she's like she's on the roof
yes she's like yeah yeah yeah keep under
up keep flying around all right wait
yeah
thank you I was gonna say that was I
think you killed her
oh my god I like don't have it in me Hey
yeah see I would say that in real life
oh my god oh there's the lantern that's
why we came here I could not I got so
stressed out
oh I like that they removed the bugs cuz
she died that's nice
there's one downstairs yeah just [ __ ]
around honestly that was like the least
they could do
yeah there's a lot of items lying around
wait no that's your psychostimulants on
you her no ID that's alright now don't
worry about don't yeah I bet you there's
all sorts of stuff down here am I on
life oh I'm on green oh yeah well I mean
my baby heart Jesus she's here
you were doing damage you weren't
shooting in her sack but I think at
least I'm pretty positive you were it
just wasn't doing as much whole this no
[ __ ] way I mean I'm fine I just I was
so stressed I like couldn't possibly
scan the area I will say I think every
time a bug came out you would back into
a corner rather than like they can't
hurt you if you keep moving because they
have to set up their sting I like
couldn't process information
like cuz she was so scary and she was
like jumping from the ceiling and I just
that's good though I mean like you use
as few items as you could I would say
and you didn't really use any other ones
lying around so now you know yeah it's
okay I mean I just like wait what's done
oh is that water so that's pretty creepy
like it's just on the swamp and that
wouldn't happen but oh yeah oh no see if
you can combine something I think it's
safe to combine one of those for health
here wait no well I was gonna say I
could take my burner out and I could
briefly and then I think that would do
it
did I lose fuel when I did that no okay
so should I take this you honestly
should just pop those right now and
right now make sure you scavenge every
into this house I'm on drugs
delicious what is that that
should I go in there now or later uh
that's just your way out that's the
front door you so go later but yeah you
can just round around here like upstairs
where you missed a few things
hurry drugs oh I miss that that must be
the way out I think that's where you
first came in oh no that's inside that
locked cabinet that you needed a lot for
I think don't drop down here why was
that I don't know I just pick stuff up
you see anything else it's not where it
was he's where off feel like drugs
should last a little longer
no I meant I just meant like in general
like don't choice which would be great
yeah well that's it like a little longer
no say like that'd be great if shrooms
wore off after like two minutes as
opposed to half an hour 45 minutes okay
so I couldn't make something cuz I'm out
of space
I could probably can't wait reload no no
go pull this up I could make a heel yeah
you're gonna need one eventually
damn you must have a lot of handgun off
that didn't stack
cool so the thing is though there's
gonna be stuff in this next area that I
can't get either then well no like this
scalp this front door you're pretty much
at the trailer
oh really yeah this is the shortcut
check it out even those you can I can
just come back yeah I mean you can yeah
yeah well I got the shortcut there's
probably also a few items littered out
here that you can get later but this is
like near the hub so do I have jobs on
oh I feel like I worked out I feel like
I yes
yeah you got the lantern you can go into
the Attic yeah which won't be scary at
all
solid fuel yeah I don't think you need
to burn our fuel
what do you mean like this thing you
definitely don't need a grenade launcher
right now you do have enough antique
coins now for the best reload unless you
want to keep saving for the Magnum I
would recommend the former though
personally because the Magnum you need
to get like all of them for not all if
you get every item obviously you need to
get all them but you don't want to get
that I'm gonna just get that while I'm
thinking about it I think now you're
going to the old house
oh I don't blame Joey for setting up
shop in the trailer I would want to live
in the house or the greenhouse or the
old house you remember where was that
toilet I thought it was right here but
no no I don't think it was in this not
this no it's I think it was what was
that photo of I don't really know it was
a toilet a nut with a ashtray full of
cigarettes next to cigarette butts so it
could be the one in the first floor of
the main house you want to go in the
attic or save it for next episode we
spend like I don't know how long it
takes like I will go right now yeah you
attic I got like another I don't think
the attic will take super long okay but
let's do it still might be scary not
after what I've seen all right so I'm
gonna save that so I got a shotgun with
not a lot of bullets a handgun with lots
of bullets and fire thing I get rid of
the fire thing I bring it then I feel
good about this you'll also put the
lantern down have an extra space I'm
just gonna save real fast okay make good
progress
you think mm-hmm I died on the bus I
think I died on the first time playing
her too
actually the first time I played her was
in Osaka at Capcom HQ for the preview of
it oh really so scary so let me paint a
picture of how long this preview event
was they sat us down said play the game
until we tell you to stop and they saw
that not bragging I was the first one to
beat Marguerite and actually I don't
know that I was but that's when they
stopped us once you kill her they're
like all right that's the end of the
preview so I had no idea how far into
the game that was like yeah that was
November 3 months before chemo that was
really fun like I usually hate preview
trips I mean see that out of context -
it would have been really weird when I
said wait wheel cycles to me let's just
passed on that box when I say I hate
pretty vents I really don't
like I love going out and playing games
before they come out that sounded like a
privilege just first world problem but
preview events inherently like obviously
it's PR kind of trying to say like oh
what do you think this they just sat me
down let me play it for five hours four
hours and then me and two more in the UK
and Adam Mason UK office all scared
aside I love that that is such a good
little subtle did you read this last
night yes I did
needless to say I knew right away at
that pretty event that I would like this
game everything you just played I played
it in one day hello mister booby head
alright here it in a coin oh you didn't
see it he's right next to the candles Oh
like that's such a satisfying stupid
lock oh you that's so mean
[Music]
it's definitely on purpose there's no
normal reason to do such a thing
day what my light went out you know what
happened
wait did it really I honestly oh it
flickered I didn't see that's me and
that plushie came alive so rude when
there's a drawer and there's nothing on
that what is that is that the window
thing at the window yeah what if it was
her again I like this chair I have to
put it on our hand gun because it's
gonna waste shock I'm gonna waste a
shell do you remember when yes I
remember it that I been looking forward
to people's reactions it's a very good
moment
my family has a lion
so yeah did you look at the picture
bunch of [ __ ] like some things
for [ __ ] sake I'll shoot
she's got no bullets but shits on her
shoes bunch of shoes
she's the lights were on this is a cool
attic like if this was all like this
attic sucks like okay I give your
parents like you get this whole second
floor in this house separate from the
mansion that's what happened
what's wrong this woman no what's a
bicycle doing up here that's really
closing it Oh Oh what is that Titanic
[ __ ] this game is really good
no can you put your hand up the butt
pull ups and shotguns shell
no I don't think I've seen that before
take it up again that's pretty gruesome
okay when was the last time I saved
there's autosave as well
it's like darker in here or something
there's something names of those books
on the shelf
sudden misery creators rights heartless
betrayal unnerve wait wait hold on
there's one on the far right listen I
have to check my six you know that they
killed him very literal
hello mr. police oh no John dies at the
end I don't have enough bullets I only
have a three yeah I wouldn't have
there's gonna be Mossman in here without
a death I remembered that one [ __ ] where
are you well obviously did you see the
pantry filled with dolls a Chandler Bing
voice did you see the pantry fell
did you see the pantry could this at it
be anything
stay away
[Music]
the new character that's pretty creepy
this chair just in a [ __ ] cage its
mom its chair cage chair who unnecessary
to have all these it's just funny like
at this point is it's actually like
really dark humor I [ __ ] should have
ended the episode
weird bedroom
oh I've seen this
this bless yeah it's like the Hey Arnold
shrine sweet [ __ ] that's gross
no so is that the little girl put on
your pocket bring it back the same room
I mean you're gonna want that what
Oh No let's mad sweetie okay staying
here forever alone either a safe grade
in here she made that she she made
sweetie
is she gonna kill me something's wrong
with her
well obviously well look at that wall
what's happening
Oh God
it's in the
sweetie there's a little girl it's in
the door isn't it in the door through
the door [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I know you're
out there
there another one keep mind you have one
shotgun seller I that's all I need was
that noise
don't go back well you always check your
six
where is it
but I know you're here
I
see it yes I'm getting better
[ __ ] you okay I'm on yellow but I'm
still okay but I'm no more chocolate
what's that noise there's another one in
there
for all from the ceiling you [ __ ]
Mossman where is it
[ __ ] no there's another one nope
where is it sit in that hole
I just noticed that's the lantern room
where is it back to her playroom
I hear it it's the one with the thing
where's it [ __ ] you oh my god I can't
deal with this
chitchat Chet back in circle I'm almost
out of bullets
[Music]
she reload
did he die arms off you kind of invested
too many bullets to run away but you
[ __ ] you what am i doing like show where
is it does he not come out I don't think
so oh Jesus I'm sorry yeah I think he's
dead do you mean to do those duck moves
cuz they're really good thanks
no okay cool
the order in which you answered those
watch out for the piano room watch out
for the piano room shot oh my god I'm
saving sweet we're done you got the
d-series arm put yeah over there sorry
wait look at one more time do not do it
cranial nerve and what I still have it
how do I put the arm back no no you
don't you oh I have to hold it you think
you just have to cranium layer for
peripheral nerve where's a peripheral
nerve I didn't go back to save her maybe
Zoe will call you or something Wow sweet
you hey what's up yeah I got it
are we really gonna be able to make
sarin with this thing it'll be fun after
we make it we can get out of here
together I'll be waiting for you in the
trailer all right oh well let's go there
okay Oh God are you choking
are you tricking me what you know what I
mean me no maybe something something
gonna kill me
please just let me get to the trailer I
have one bullet some gunpowder and chem
fluid bag the trailer I think if the
trailer was just gone
I would [ __ ] be so pissed
now where the hell are you you know
never mind we only need the head and
you've got it
this is gonna help me right buddy you
should know I've decided that Zoey
needed a timeout
she and Leah are here with me keeping
each other company
just let them both go what do you need
them for no that's family business Ethan
not your concern
understand feel free to come by anytime
and now give it to you but only if you
pay no little an activity I'll put
together what activity oh I know you're
excited but don't worry it's not going
anywhere
first step I need you to take partner is
gonna take inside the fridge in the
trailer there [ __ ] you come on you wanna
have fun don't you now
Oh de humans the pig is waiting for you
in the dissection room [ __ ] hit the pig
oh the cop so it's saying damn look how
gross that is so it's like showing them
like slowly become these things you must
have killed it oh is that the cops head
no is it that looks like a woman yeah
either way I guess you get it back to
the dissection I mean definitely not
today because my heart can't take it
you could you could get that fast reload
if you well yeah let's do it let's spend
some money I've earned it I've I have
earned it what that boss I think was
like one of the scariest bosses I think
I've ever experienced in my life
this one right yeah stable no that's a
stabilized yeah that's the first reload
oh and then what's this Magnum we want
that
but we don't need it because you need
Magnum ammo well I think you can make it
once you I don't think you'll start
picking up Magnum em unless you I think
it uses a regular hand I have nine so I
can start it with a canine now you don't
have 700 figure it out let's figure it
out next episode we can take some more
time no we're done I don't know I like
fast reload but you doing it it's kind
of a slow way to do it how do I do that
relaxes the muscles and reduces stress I
think that would be super helpful oh
yeah and then I can start this like are
there other cages that'll come across
seven more seven more payments than that
gum that motherfucker's my save one more
time oh you bet your buns I'm saving
that I'm never doing that again bet your
bottom buttocks yeah she sucks on the
next episode of Knievel the penultimate
I take on the brother and then save the
two women all glory to me yeah cuz you
killed Jack killed Margaery I got Lucas
who set up an activity for you okay I
think the next episode will be
interesting and the way it changes how
you look at the game alright sweet
alright have fun at the game wards thank
you be over by the time this happened
yeah we're recording this before the
game where's the game of words what
happened
game words are in three days from now
but yeah we recorded the earliest week
it's correct cuz I went to the game have
fun your snooty stuck-up game over party
somebody's jealous